mesdames et messieurs merci d'accueillir
le premier maître de cérémonie de cette
48e édition des Césars monsieur Jamel
Debbouze
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous
je suis très honoré et éclaté d'être
avec vous ce soir pour la 48e cérémonie
des Césars merci Maxime Saada Véronique
merci beaucoup
comme vous le savez cette année nous
avons décidé de d'opter pour une coop
présentation
pourquoi une compréhension
pour l'unité le partage la cohésion
mais c'est surtout parce que personne ne
voulait le présenter tout ça
quand même c'est Adal pas trop de Canal+
est venu me voir il m'a dit tu sais
Jamel tu es la première personne à qui
j'ai pensé pour présenter les Césars
ah tu sais que Jamel j'avais tout de
suite qui mentait
j'ai appris qu'il avait proposé à 5
personnes avant
ils ont tous refusé cher bien fait pour
ta gueule
si si il y a Corinne à zéro qui s'est
proposé volontairement mais l'Académie
était un peu subtile c'est quand même
une soirée habillée faut pas déconner
la vérité je comprends mes collègues je
comprends leur refus ça devient
dangereux de présenter ce genre de
cérémonie
tu es pas à l'abri d'une Will Smith
tu vois un mec vénère qui monte sur
scène il met une grande claque dans la
gueule
c'est pour ça je surveille on sait
jamais si
c'est qui l'équivalent de Will Smith
dans la salle pour nous donner
t'imagines denimeux il arrive il
devenait il met une grande claque dans
la gueule
lui il te met une claque tu parles
chinois tout de suite
non non
je vais pas prendre de risques ce soir
au maximum je ferai des petites vannes
sur pierre nine et lui il est prenables
non sérieux mais malgré les dangers
mesdames messieurs j'ai accepté avec
plaisir et des aventures de présenter
cette cérémonie franchement ça me fait
kiffer merci infiniment de m'avoir fait
confiance
néanmoins
j'ai imposé les conditions siliconol je
voulais être le premier à fouler cette
scène
non pas par vanité ou Hugo de mesurer
bien que
mais parce que c'est le meilleur moment
de la soirée mesdames messieurs là je
sais pas si vous vous rendez compte
c'est le moment où tout le monde est
content tout le monde est détendu tout
le monde est plein d'espoir tu vas
Virginie firasdinchala je l'ai
je te le souhaite cousine je te souhaite
du fond du cœur je te jure moi j'adore
ce moment c'est vrai
c'est le moment le plus touchant c'est
fait du bruit pour le meilleur moment de
la soirée mesdames messieurs allez-y du
bruit je vais vous entendre
du bruit
ouais c'est génial c'est génial tout le
monde est content
comment il est content regarde comment
il kiffe ça rigole rigole j'aimerais
bien voir ta gueule à 22h qu'on va
ouvrir l'enveloppe ça sera encore Benoît
Magimel qui va la voir
profiter de ce moment à fond
sur tous les nommés surtout les nommés
oui c'est vrai parce qu'au fur et à
mesure de la soirée au fil des Césars il
y en a qui vont être déçu
ça c'est pas nous c'est mathématiques
pour un César 1 heureux 4 d'ici
pour deux César des heureux
pour 3 Césars 3 heureux sur marmite 3
Césars 3 euros
d'ailleurs j'ai une pensée émue pour
tous ceux qui vont pas la voir
je suis passé par là
c'est horrible comme sensation
inutile
je marche dans la rue tu parles tout
seul
mais attention pour ceux qui vont pas
l'avoir vous êtes filmés
il faudra il faut être bon perdant il
faut pas
non parce que d'après les statistiques
les gens ils regardent plus ceux qui
l'ont pas que ceux qui l'ont
c'est important ce que je vous dis
restez digne reste-t-il digne voilà et
c'est dur à jouer la dignité tout le
monde n'y arrive pas d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs monsieur madame de l'Académie
on devrait créer un César pour ça
tu le César de celui qui l'a pas et qui
fait le mieux semblant d'être content
pour celui qui l'a
et moi
moi
César je l'attribuerai sans hésiter à
Gilles Lellouche
comment il fait bien celui qui l'a pas
il est dégoûté ça se voit jamais ça se
voit pas il a envie de mourir à
l'intérieur ces hommes mais c'est
impossible on voit rien Jules c'est une
écoute on te kiffe comprends mal
tu nous manques
les Trèves de baliverne
comme disent Truffaut
je sais aussi que sur la fait appel à
moi c'est pour faire des blagues et pour
éviter de dire la vérité
mais madame la ministre d'abord ça va la
baisse bien
ouais il paraît qu'il serait mis il
serait mise à mal par des nids Amazon
par Amazon Disney et duo ou autre
et ils sont nombreux ces bâtards
mais qu'est-ce qu'ils ont de plus que
nous
alors oui c'est vrai pour le Ferro tu as
un accès illimité à des très très bons
filmscher c'est vrai oui c'est vrai pour
9 euros tu as tes acteurs incroyables
comme DiCaprio Depardieu Meryl Streep ou
encore Sandra Bullock j'adore Sandra
Bullock comment ils ont fait pour
l'avoir pour 9 €
non mais sérieux
tu peux regarder des films
confortablement dans ton salon ou avec
ta femme dans ton lit tu peux mettre
pause aller chercher un yaourt revenir
et tout ça pour la maudite somme du 9
euros
pas moi
les bâtards
alors oui c'est vrai madame monsieur
cette offre est exceptionnelle et on est
dans la merde
mais
on est le cinéma
on est le cinéma on n'est pas le cinéma
et on est le meilleur cinéma d'Europe
même
oui
et je sais comment le rester moi j'ai
des solutions concrètes pour ça
le prix des places par exemple c'est un
sujet oui c'est vrai c'est cher
pour un couple si tu additionne le prix
de deux places plus le pop-corn plus la
nounou ça fait 60 euros minimum c'est
cher
mais j'ai une solution il faut baisser
le prix de la nuit nous
voilà
elles sont aussi sur le canapé pendant
que les enfants ils dorment et qu'est-ce
qu'elles font elles regardent Netflix
vous vous rendez compte ou pas vous
la tête de ma mère regarde Netflix et
elle mange mes yaourts
non c'est un scandale si lui nounou le
souci là je déconne je déconne c'est du
second degré j'ai pas envie d'avoir des
problèmes avec les loulous tu imagines
toi une nouvelle vénère qui monte sur
scène et qui me jette du lactose dans
les yeux ou un truc comme ça non autre
proposition qu'est-ce qui marche en ce
moment au cinéma
avatar Astérix Top Gun les cascades des
effets spéciaux
j'ai regardé le film d'auteur
pas une cascade pas un effet spécial
c'est normal ça non mais sérieusement
vous voulez faire des entrées ou pas
franchement il faut booster nos
scénarios il faut être plus créatif je
sais pas mais tu es Anaïs de moustique
dans un avion de chasse elle fait la
même taille que Tom Cruise c'est sûr ça
passe
ou on a qu'à inventé un avatar à la
française tu vois si c'est des hommes en
bleu de travail
et au lieu de se battre pour sauver la
nature il se battent pour sauver leur
retraite tu vois on a les sujets on les
a
on les a les sujets la capote
ça ne tient qu'à vous attends et si et
si on n'a pas le budget pour les avatars
pour des avions de chasse mais qui dit
ninjas ça coûte pas cher des ninja mais
dès le scénario fait les maîtres tu vois
parce que quand je dis je suis désolé
Vincent Lindon marche langoureusement
vers Juliette Binoche à langoureusement
on a vidé la salle
si tu remplaces langoureusement par des
ninjas sur la vie de ma mère c'est pas
le même film
tu imagines Vincent Lindon il marche
comme ça nombreusement vers juillet de
Binoche il se fait attaquer par des
ninjas de part et d'autre
là il se passe quelque chose
moi je vous fais des
Juliette oui c'est vrai mais
attendez pas ça
tu rajoutes des ninjas Juliette sur la
vie de ma mère on fait un malheur
je l'ai vu le film bien sûr
qu'est-ce qui lui arrive à elle
c'est pourquoi c'est pas ce qu'on croit
aussi les mains et qu'on l'aime
et c'est un endroit où tu t'es possible
je suis la preuve vivante de Juliette
c'est un endroit qui permet de rêver
d'être n'importe qui on peut rentrer
dans la vie de n'importe quelle
personnage regarde elle
il a fait un braqueur alors qu'il a
jamais voulu une sucette c'est sûr
pourtant onze nominations bravo mesdames
messieurs on peut l'applaudir l'innocent
Bouli Lanners qui jouent un policier
alors qu'il devrait être en cellule de
dégrisement
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est pas la magie du cinéma ça
d'illumination Brabois Dominique malle
bravo bravo
pour la nuit du 12
Benoît Magimel qui joue en commissaire
de la République bravo l'ami fantastique
prestation
magnifique frère j'ai adoré pour de vrai
pacifications pacifix
d'Albert serra 9 nominations waouh vous
avez décroché la timbale
super
bravo à Cédric la pige mon poto il est
où Cédric yo Cédric 9 levulation pour
encore
et
un double bras avant pour Valéria brûlée
Gimenez pour leur sept nominations
respectives
novembre et les amandiers bravo bravo
bravo bravo bravo et surtout un grand
bravo à James Hut pour ses 0 nominations
pour le nouveau jouet ça ça m'a
ça m'a énervé ça mais ça m'a touché
aussi
non sérieusement mesdames messieurs et
après je m'en vais je voulais vous dire
qu'il moi qui viens du spectacle vivant
je peux vous dire que là où personne ne
pourra jamais rivaliser avec nous c'est
sur l'expérience de ça
parce qu'il y a rien de plus fort que la
communion de la publique voir un film
partagé des rires des émotions ensemble
ça personne ne pourra jamais nous le
prendre c'est sûr et quand je regarde
cette salle Juliette quand je te vois
toi et que je vois tous par terre quand
je pense à notre cinéma à tous ces
talents ces acteurs ses actrices les
réalisateurs les réalisatrices les
techniciens les machines
quand je pense à ça et quand je vous
vois je me dis que c'est vous la
solution en fait
alors ayez confiance en vous et vive le
cinéma
merci